whether it's introducing an iconic
character creating a mind-blowing battle
or surprising fans with the unexpected
first impressions are key to a
successful superhero cinematic universe
with that in mind let's take a look at
some of the genres greatest opening
scenes Batman these days Batman is
everywhere but in 1989 comic book fans
were still waiting for the Dark Knight
to take over the silver screen
they were also ready for something
darker than TVs Batman something that
felt more like the comics written by
Alan Moore and Frank Miller director Tim
Burton was able to impress even the most
die-hard fans with his gothic take on
Gotham City in this opening scene a city
cloaked in darkness with buildings that
looked like they'd been designed by a
drunken Fritz Lang insert Batman two
thugs having recently mugged a family
are busy counting their ill-gotten cash
win
but bullets can't stop Batman
[Music]
and then we get to hear the most iconic
superhero line of all time I'm Batman
just like that a cinematic hero is born
blade long before the MCU existed there
was 1998's blade the first successful
Marvel movie directed by Stephen
Norrington the Films opening fight scene
was hailed by critics as the best set
piece in comic book history a man is
lured inside the world's nastiest
nightclub by a beautiful woman and we
witness his revulsion as he realizes the
ceiling is rigged with blood spurting
sprinklers then they start bearing fangs
and we realized this poor sap is about
to become dinner but before the feast
begins in comes a sword wielding
superhero the half-human half-vampire
blade played by Wesley Snipes he steaks
blasts and cuts with an impressive array
of weapons this opening grabs your
attention right off the bat spider-man -
what makes Tobey Maguire's spider-man so
relatable is that underneath the costume
he's just an ordinary guy with ordinary
problems directed by Sam Raimi the film
finds Peter Parker on the verge of
losing his job at a pizza restaurant
with only seven and a half minutes to
make a career saving delivery
Peter changes into his Spidey suit
he stole a gas of course spider-man
can't help but rescue some kids from an
oncoming truck but he loses his job when
he delivers the pizzas late being super
isn't all it's cracked up to be
especially when you're broke lonely and
tired of saving everyone but yourself
the dark night the opening to 2008's The
Dark Knight is one of the all-time
greats filmed on 70 millimeter IMAX
Christopher Nolan's masterpiece begins
with the creeping score that warns us
somethings up just before a bunch of
thugs wearing clown masks kick off an
elaborate heist they take over a bank
bantering about the Joker their
enigmatic boss as they work they pick
each other off one by one until there's
only one thug standing before he can get
away an injured mob enforcer asks him
respect look at you what do you believe
in huh
that's when the clown pulls off his mask
to reveal the horrific face of the Joker
the Clown Prince of Crime has been there
the whole time
as he prepares to make his getaway he
delivers his chilling credo I believe
whatever doesn't kill you simply makes
you
stranger watchmen say what you want
about the movie as a whole but there's
no denying that the opening to Zack
Snyder's Watchmen perfectly captures the
bloody beat down of Alan Moore's graphic
novel we open on the comedian a
so-called superhero who's done more
dirty deeds than derring-do the grizzled
nihilist is alone contemplating life's
many sick jokes when a mysterious
opponent storms into the room as the
shadowy assassin beats the comedian into
oblivion Snyder employs his trademark
slow-mo the entire fight is underscored
by Nat King Cole's unforgettable and as
the comedian is tossed out the window
we're left with an opening no superhero
fan will ever forget Deadpool we all
know that Deadpool doesn't play by the
rules and neither does the opening of
his r-rated blockbuster who would have
thought that a movie about a deformed
mutant assassin would open with juice
Newton's angel of the morning the song
plays as the camera winds through a
suspended tableau of destruction while
the hilarious credits tell us to watch
out for God's perfect idiot a hot chick
and a British villain of course the
awesomeness doesn't stop there
immediately after the credits we see the
Merc with a mouth perched on an overpass
jamming to shoot Deadpool breaks the
fourth wall to say hello to the audience
oh oh hello before jumping off the
overpass and landing in an SUV full of
villains we get to watch the slow-mo
credits play out in real time Gauri and
hysterically over-the-top it sets the
perfect tone for the madness to follow
did I leave the stove on guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 when your 2017 movie
starts with a 1980s Kurt Russell you
know you're doing something right
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 opens with
ego the Living Planet and Meredith quill
cruising down backroads of Missouri
we're caught up in the romance of it all
not to mention the amazing digital work
done to Russell's face the lazy
afternoon doesn't last long though
Showtime
holls 34 years into the future
everyone's favorite a-holes are
preparing for battle and as you can
expect bickering when an oversized space
squid comes tearing out of the sky the
ensuing fight is accompanied by Electric
Light Orchestra blasting on the stereo
baby Groot dancing to elo is possibly
the most adorable seen in the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe one that took
two whole years of planning really the
only thing better than watching baby
Groot boogie is watching director James
Gunn choreograph all the dance moves
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]